there is
one drug in that kit of drugs that's
very unusual like psilocybin lsd those
promote
heavy heavy serotonin release and
lateralized connections ramp up etc matt
talked about all that
but mdma ecstasy
is a very unusual situation where
dopamine is
very very high because of the the way
the drug is designed
dopamine release it goes through the
roof so people feel
great and they want to move and they
have a lot of energy
but serotonin levels are also high and
that's a very unnatural state
and why mdma may may and i want to
highlight may have particularly
high potential for the treatment of
certain forms of depression
is an interesting question because never
before in
as far as we know in human history has
there been
a possibility of opening up dopaminergic
and serotonergic states at the same time
dopamine being the molecule pursuit and
reward and more and more
and serotonin being one of bliss and
being content right where you're at so
it's almost like those two things wrap
back on themselves and create this very
unusual state
and i think the bigger conversation is
what to do with a state like that
like do you is it about self-love
is it about developing love for another
person is it about forgetting hate
like these are powerful molecules and i
think if the academic community
and the clinical community is going to
move forward with them in any serious
way
i think there needs to be a conversation
about what
they're being used for
you